today the spring semester started at the
southern nevada urban micro academy
the academy was created by the city of
north las vegas to give vulnerable
students a place to go during distance
learning
hector mejia is live there with a closer
look at how the program is working
hector good afternoon
good afternoon and this program was
launched back in august
enrollment went up for this new semester
and this recreation center here right
behind me is one of three places
that i have been transformed into
in-person learning centers here in the
city of north las vegas
and earlier this morning we found some
excited students to be back in a
classroom setting
the southern nevada urban micro academy
kicked off the new spring semester with
councilwoman pamela goins brown
handing out face masks now the program
ended the fall semester with 50 students
they're starting the new one with 74 and
there's still space for more
it's for students in grades one through
eight they get personalized attention in
small class sizes
which are staffed by former or retired
teachers
during the fall we were told that all of
the fifth and sixth graders came in
below grade level students are making
significant
growth now thanks to this program
this is our future i don't want to see
any child
not progress academically once you start
falling behind it's so difficult to make
up those gaps
and this is one way that we can ensure
that the kids are progressing the
program
is sound it's solid and it follows the
state standards which is a requirement
so they hope to keep the program as long
as they can parents can go to
nlvcares.com the information is
available in both english and spanish
and there are two requirements though
students need to be residents in the
city of north las vegas and
they must unenroll from the clark county
school district
there's also no cost to the parents but
they need to submit an application
and students are allowed to return to
the clark county school district
once schools reopen and that's if they
want to reporting in north las vegas
hector mejia
8 news now